so i think the biggest and hardest
lesson
is that your purpose is like a
rare jewel and a rare
gemstone and imagine you were walking
around with the most expensive
diamond or jewel in the world how would
you protect it
i really believe that you have to seek
the love and the beauty that you want
in what you have now
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation
top 10.
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more
and you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best
jay shetty and my take on his top 10
rules for success
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one be
humble anytime you have a negative
thought that's the mind
right any time you have a negative
thought you have a thought that's taking
you away from a higher principle of
collaboration
connection humanity any time you have a
thought
of harming someone else anytime you have
a thought of revenge making someone else
look bad any of those things you
know it's that inner voice that tells
you it right that's how you know
the difference really when you walk a
thousand miles in someone else's shoes
you realize that you don't envy them
right
robin robert she had this great quote
she said if we all chucked our problems
into the middle
of a room or whatever it is we'd all
grab ours back
right when you really look at the
struggle and challenges that people have
been through
it doesn't seem so attractive so
how can we find a solution to being
envied really
always be humble always be grounded if
there's people that are envying you
always express yourself in the most
servant leader format right don't ever
let them don't ever let it feel like
reality
be yourself be humble be grounded in
that way
rule number two protect your purpose
what's been the biggest lesson in the
last
12 months for you because you've learned
you've created so much in the last 12
months you've done so many things
what's been the biggest lesson for you
in your life well that's a great
question
i think i'd have to say that it's a and
i was saying it to a friend on the phone
this morning when i was on the way to
you
and i was just i was just sharing it
with him because he was having a moment
in recognizing this
there's a wonderful verse in the
manusmithi
which i talk about and think like a monk
it's a monk book and in the verse it
says
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects
you now i wanna i wanna unpack that what
i mean by that is
your purpose is like a rare jewel
and a rare gemstone and
imagine you were walking around with the
most expensive
diamond or jewel in the world how would
you protect it you want to just like
you would just you want to wear it on
your chest like this like a baby holding
it
yeah putting a pillow around a blanket
you do like yeah protect it you'd
protect it
and so your purpose is like that and
guess what people are going to tell you
every day that that jewel is not worth
anything
they're going to tell you that that
jewel is actually
valueless it doesn't have any impact on
your life they're going to try and take
away that value they're going to tell
you that there's another jewel out there
that you need
to have more value and what ends up
happening is you don't i love the word
look at the wording protect your purpose
you have to protect it so what happens
is your success grows
you get more opportunities more ideas
more things coming your way temptations
but they can all take you away from your
perspective
distractions and to me i'm repeating
this for myself because i'm like i just
want to stick
to what i was born to do and i'm so
grateful that i get to do it i'm so
happy i get to do it and i want to keep
protecting it i don't want to get lost
in the waves
you know you don't want to just get
chucked in the waves of the ocean and
just get lost and just not know where
you're going so for me
when you protect your purpose your
purpose protects you rule number three
find the missing puzzle piece sometimes
it's just what you're fascinated with
right now that's right because i think
sometimes we make it too big and we're
like oh well
what's my big purpose or what's my big
service to the world and it's like well
what moves you right now like what are
you interested in right now when
i mean mine was totally the opposite way
i i grew up as a really shy kid i'm
right down the middle of intro and extra
too
and my parents forced me to go to public
speaking drama school when i was 14
years old oh my god because they were
scared that i was too shy and i was too
much of an introvert
and i didn't know how to communicate so
my parents forced me to go from my
school it's an extracurricular activity
i went three times a week three hours
every week from ages 14 to 18.
wow the practice the exams that we were
examined
on reading a paragraph from a book with
tonality
and being able to bring a story to life
just through
words and visuals and then being able to
there was this thing called
impromptu presentations where you got a
subject five minutes before you had to
go in and talk about it and you'd be
able to talk about it and you couldn't
say anything that wasn't
true so you had to make sure that it was
all factual and whatever you did
research in those five to 10 15 minutes
was right and and i remember doing that
and
i get to the end of that i was like oh
well i've got this skill now but i don't
know what to use it for because that's
basically what i was like at 18
yeah oh so i've learned how to do public
speaking i'm now four years into my
london academy of music drama and arts
and i've got
you know gold medal in this this this
but i was like what do i do with this
because i had nothing to talk about
and then when i started studying
philosophy from the eastern perspective
of the vedas and the bhagavad gita i was
like
oh this is what i was meant to learn it
for
like it almost like was i had a skill
with no service sure
and and i don't want that's what i'm
saying if you're listening to this right
now and you have a skill with no service
don't worry or if you have a service
with no skill don't worry that's right
you know just go and find the missing
piece of the jigsaw you just gave us
yes this four-piece jigsaw you just gave
us chances are you probably have one of
them
yeah and then you can go and build the
other three but don't worry about having
all of them now
rule number four embrace polarities i
think the two things that we're all
working towards
is a sense of peace and a sense of
purpose
peace is for yourself and purposes for
the world and i think we all exist in
both places
and i think where we go wrong is that we
try to live
life in an either or and this was one of
the most beautiful lessons that i
learned as a monk
the life was about self and about
service
there was no either or it wasn't
disconnected or divided you couldn't
live a life
of complete selfishness and expect to be
happy that wouldn't work
even if you look at like hedonism if you
look at it as a philosophy of life or
hedonism
however it's pronounced here but if you
look at that as a philosophy of life
which is
let's just accumulate let's just hoard
and let's just celebrate on my own
we know people and stories about people
who will not be satisfied that way
to just have you're one of them you and
lisa
and i and i can say this honestly and i
said this to liz the other day
are two of the most generous loving
people and humble people that i know
despite all your success and incredible
achievement
and that's what endears people to you
it's not what you have that india's
people that may endear some people to
you
but what keeps the right people around
is that you both have these human
qualities because you want to serve you
want to help you want to support and
collaborate
and so for me i feel like we either live
and then we leave the opposite the other
opposite life is our life is just about
giving
it's just about service it's just about
helping that's not sustainable either
and so to me i've discovered through
real monk wisdom that life is actually
embracing polarities
it's actually about doing a dance and
knowing
which way to go at the right time so i
believe as much in strategy
as i do in sincerity and i believe in
much
as generosity as i do in generating
value for myself
and i believe as much in giving as i do
in growing
and i think as soon as you start to say
no it's either or you have to choose
i think that's where we start to lose a
part of ourselves and that's why i
add that compassion to passion because i
know a lot of people who do what they
are passionate about but actually lack
meaning and purpose in their life
because they haven't turned it into a
service
everyone i have been reading a bit from
my friend's book evan carmichael built
to serve and i wanted to share this with
you
so according to a study by carnegie
mellon university
people with supportive spouses are more
likely to give themselves
the chance to succeed they studied 163
married couples
and found that people with supportive
spouses were more likely to take on
potentially rewarding challenges
those who accepted challenges
experienced more personal growth
happiness and psychological well-being
now i can truly say that i've
experienced that in my life when i first
met my wife i was
just starting out i had never released a
video i hadn't created any content
and she was such an important part of
feeling supported on that journey so
whether you're in a relationship whether
you're dating whether you're married or
even if you're single
being supported by friends and a strong
community is important
uh build to serve by evan carmichael
great book
on how you can find your purpose and
also on reminding us
that we can all make a difference in the
world thanks evan rule number five
set rules about social media use i just
really have had to build up rules around
my social media use
you have so my rule is never look at the
phone first thing in the morning
oh my gosh i am really trying this is my
biggest one
i think if we did this we would conquer
our lives
i have now not looked at instagram first
thing in the morning i just look at like
the text the email okay we're good
i that's good yep that's huge it is for
me
that's huge at one point i actually used
to put my phone and my laptop locked in
my car downstairs
well because that was the only way i
could truly convince myself
not to look at my phone and i think we
have to go to that extent sometimes with
that extremity to really push ourselves
out of it so i don't look at my phone
until i go down to the gym which is two
hours after i meditate and wake up and
everything so i try and avoid looking at
my phone for those first two hours
and i find what that does is it gives
your mind time to warm up
you don't start your mind on someone
else's reactive schedule right when you
wake up and you look at that email you
look at that notification you're now
thinking about everything everyone wants
you to do
not what you want to do right you're not
thinking about who you want to be
or what you want to achieve you're
thinking about oh mary wants me to get
that right
you know julie wants me to do that right
like whatever it is like you start
thinking about everyone else's schedule
and then the third thing that happens is
and i've said this before but i think
it's really powerful when when you think
about it i think about this in the
morning it really stops me
none of us and i mean literally none of
us would let a hundred people
walk into our bedroom first thing in the
morning that's true
ever before doing your hair before you
do maybe your makeup getting clothes on
having a shower
you would never do that but we let 100
notifications enter our mind
that's literally trying to shake our
consciousness awake right it's like
really trying to wake your mind up
you're expecting your mind
going from zero to 60 miles per hour in
five seconds when you open up instagram
or whatsapp or emails
and it's so much pressure on our minds
that's really all it is it's
pressure and stress for your mind to
have to wake up and warm up
way quicker than our bodies do so that's
been a huge one for me that rule
rule number six start with the basics
the pressure of finding your purpose
is crazy will stop you from finding your
purpose absolutely the pressure is so
heavy
and that's why it's not about finding
that it's just starting with the basics
what am i good at and i talk about it i
break down dharma in here and i talk
about what are your passion
what is your expertise what is your
compassion
because that's really important what is
your compassion for the world like
what problem do you want to solve i
often people will say there's so many
things i could do there's so many things
i'm like
my question is not what causes you the
greatest joy sometimes my question is
what is what causes you the greatest
pain
make that your purpose make that your
purpose if you don't know what your joy
is you definitely know what your pain is
like using the world what do you not
like and so for me
go serve that thing 100 so for me the
greatest pain i see in the world
is people not reaching their potential
that is that causes me more pain because
i believe
that there is someone out there who is
stacking shelves who has the cure
to cancer right there is someone out
there or a talented singer
he's a talented singer there is someone
out there who's not living to their
potential
and i think we're better people we're
better partners and we're better parents
when we live to our potential so that's
what i'm trying to solve and i'm not
saying that's the biggest thing sure
you're saying it's my thing
rule number seven go all in on your
strengths
how do you help people
develop their strengths and recognize
what their strengths are in the first
place
and calm that monkey mind so that they
can see clearly
this is this is why i love tom you're
just amazing tommy you're literally
explaining my book for me i'm just like
this is like the biggest masterclass of
the book it's great uh
no and you're spot on that the monkey
mind
is what we all experience every day so
the monkey mind is jumping from branch
to branch
it doesn't want to focus on the root of
the issue it wants to find the next
banana it wants to find the next excuse
it wants to find the next instant
gratification right that's the monkey
mind
and so the monkey mind is never going to
help you
focus on your strengths and the reason
going back to one of the earlier
questions you asked the reason why we
struggle to find our passion
is because the world has constantly
pushed us away from our strengths
we've constantly told to focus on your
weaknesses oh you've got three a's and a
d you should be working on that
d let's get that up to an a right i
remember
in my school they had this excruciating
exercise
where you'd be ranked 1 to 180
on every subject every year and they'd
send the list home to your parents
so there were 180 students in my year
group and every subject art
math english science geography history
you name it
you were ranked 1 to 180 in every
subject
based on your test results and scores
and that was like
painful when my parents received that
and the crazy thing was i would
always outperform always in art design
philosophy and economics i was in
english i was always in the top
half if not in the top quarter if not in
the top five
right of my whole year group and stuff
like science and geography
and math i was kind of like in the
middle
and and towards the bottom end of my
year now granted i went to a competitive
school so i was still okay at those
things
but the interesting thing was that my
parents and my friends parents
would never look at what you came one or
two or three in
they'd be looking at the things you came
90 100 110 in
and so we've all been programmed to say
oh your strengths are they're fine
they're good the way they are but why
are you not performing at this
and so the one way to know your
strengths
is to ask yourself what do you do
that you feel the most confidence doing
and it could be something as simple as
i'm great at organizing birthday parties
it could be like that may be your skill
right that may be your strength or it
may be something like i'm really good at
putting on makeup
or it could be that i have a great sense
of fashion
it could be any of those things and if
you don't know it yet
you can also do an exercise where you
sit down with a colleague a family
member and a friend
because you need people from all areas
of your life and you ask them what do
you think i
do that i excel in that i stand out in
or if you could trust me to do one thing
in your life for you what would that one
thing be
and when you ask that to people in a
reflective way really asking for that
presence
you might be surprised by what they say
and that's such a powerful
question to ask because someone may
actually say something like to you
like jay i think your greatest strength
is
just knowing what to say to me when i
most need it
and you may think well that's not a
strength you can do anything with
but it is it is a strength that you can
do a lot with
if you are okay with accepting that of
course i want someone to say to me
oh jay you're you're an athlete like
cristiano ronaldo and
you could play football and get the
ballon d'or and win all these trips but
that's not my reality
and so i feel that that's the place that
i would start with strengths
and there was a great study done on
the healthy wealthy and wisest people in
the world
and they were asked if you could invest
in what you're good at
you're average at or what you're bad at
where would you put your money and so if
you take 100 how would you divide that
as a ratio
and if you ask this i want everyone
who's listening and watching at home
right now to do this exercise
and you may write down 33 33 33 you may
write down
40 40 20 you may write down 10 1080
whatever you write down the most healthy
wealthy wisest successful people on the
planet
will say theirs is a hundred zero or 80
10 10
they go all in on their strengths
because they know that if they go
all in on their strengths they can
become exceptional at it
now here's the caveat when it comes to
your hard skills
focus on your strengths but when it
comes to your soft skills
focus on your weaknesses now you got to
tell me which is which yeah so hard
skills
are things like excel math uh
product design using a video camera uh
script writing speaking these are all
hard skills in the sense that they're
uh very clearly defined very tangible
uh you can really measure them it's
almost like a skill that's measurable
your soft skills are like emotional
intelligence
listening compassion empathy
these are all soft skills or considered
soft skills
and those are where you focus on your
weaknesses because they can actually end
up tripping you up
while you're trying to become the best
at doing the hard skill
so you may be the best videographer in
the world but if you don't know how to
listen to your community
and your team then no one's going to
want to work with you
and so to me that's the missing link
that we're actually the other way around
we put
all our emphasis on getting better at
our weaknesses and our hard skills
and we think that because we're
empathetic and good people that that
will be enough
and it doesn't work that way rule number
eight have deep
faith what is faith to you faith to me
like the two polarities is the
day-to-day practices
and the map so it's the thing that's
guiding every decision
right it's the thing that's guiding
every direction that i move in
it's the thing that guys who i want to
be friends with who i want to connect
with the type of work i want to do
but then it's also what i do daily and
to me that's what's so beautiful about
faith that it can be
practical and simple but then it can be
philosophical and spiritual
yeah and so to me faith is both because
if i'm not practicing on a daily basis
how can it last
right and if it's not the governing
thing behind all my decisions
then how is it true like how is it real
how is it your moral compass also
exactly yeah so for me it's both of
those things at all times
and so it's everything i do in the
morning so my meditation practices
my prayer the way i communicate how i
speak to my wife like i think all of
those things how i speak to anyone right
i think all of those things are my faith
and at the same time it's like do i am i
doing this out of love am i doing this
out of service
am i taking this decision just because
it pays the bills and just because it
makes money or am i doing this just
because i think it will be cool
it's the same as it's so funny you asked
me this question because i was speaking
to someone about you just before coming
the show today
really yes i was saying one of the
things i love about ashley and why i
think we get along so well and we find
it so easy to connect is because we both
have such deep faith yes and i said i
always find it easier when you meet
someone who has their
faith and it may be different but
they're open and then you just connect
and that's how i feel with you that when
we first started talking and meeting i
felt it straight away
the people who are really rooted in
their faith and that comes before
anything else
i always connect yeah rule number nine
learn
to talk to yourself learn how to have a
conversation with yourself
like just learn how to have a
conversation with yourself
like if you don't know if i'll give it
one of the studies that i share in the
book which i absolutely love uh men and
women were asked
either to be alone with their thoughts
for 15 minutes
or they could give themselves an
electric shock if they were bored
they took a shot 30 of women chose an
electric shark
and 60 of men chose an electric shock
because they didn't want to be alone
with their thoughts for 15 minutes for
15 minutes
why is that because we have not learned
to have a conversation
with ourselves or even love ourselves
no we haven't and i think that starts
with the conversation i think you're
right we don't love ourselves but that
starts with learning to talk to yourself
so
find time for you to talk to your own
mind to talk to yourself to understand
yourself to
find out how many of us when you go to a
restaurant you know whether you're going
to go back or not
based on whether you like the food when
you watch a movie you know whether
you're going to recommend it to your
friends
based on whether you liked it or not why
do we keep visiting
the same people the same places and
doing the same projects
when they don't lift us up so many of us
are not aware of the same people that we
hang around with that bring us down
the places that don't feed us they drain
our energy and the projects that don't
light us up yeah but we keep going back
there because we don't talk to ourselves
because we don't talk to ourselves
because no one like i can ask you hey
did you like that restaurant
but when do we ask ourselves hey do what
do i like do i want to hang out with
that person does that person
want to be in this relationship we
and rule number 10 the last one before
very special bonus clip
is lead by example so i think the
biggest
and hardest lesson is that
our family and our friends will be more
inspired by our example than our
education
they're gonna change when they see us
change they're gonna transform when they
see us genuinely transformed
their
they're they're not fascinated by how
much you've learned and how much you
know and you can do a headstand now
and you know you can you know you can do
all these chakras and mudras and you
know all these sanskrit words and you
know like
that that doesn't move the people that
have known you since you were young
or have known you before and that
doesn't make an impact on them what
makes an impact in them is
your example and your transformation and
the amount you've changed i remember
this was really tough so someone asked a
similar question but in a
not as nicely as you did you you asked
it very respectfully
but i remember when when i was in when i
was a monk one
this question was asked to my teacher
and my teacher was actually very
compassionate but this was one of his
like
heavier moments of of like it was harsh
but he was asked by someone in the crowd
they said to him they said i'm trying
so hard to you know get my family to
become spiritual and i'm doing
everything and they don't listen to me
and i'm trying really hard and it's not
working and i'm like
doing this and i'm doing that i'm doing
this i'm teaching them this i'm taking
this and nothing's happening
and my teacher said to them and they
were a student of his and my teacher
said to them they said he said
tolerate them as i'm tolerating you
and i was like
and so he actually said and he's super
sweet like my teacher is like 70 years
old he's been a monk for four years he's
amazing he's one of the sweetest people
in the world and he said that i was like
whoa
i was like you just got served yeah like
it was it was one of those moments
and and you know he's in robes and he
says it really peacefully and everything
but
but the lesson i got from that
the lesson i got from that is that
someone's done that for us
like someone's been patiently waiting
for me to transform for me to grow
whether it's a mentor or a guide a guru
a teacher or
whatever it is like there's someone in
our life in any transformation
who's also waiting for us so part of it
is patience
patience is a huge thing you're never
going to change
someone or make them do something and
half the time you just have to get out
of the way
the the part with patients that works is
introduce them to who they're inspired
by don't try and be their inspiration
right and i often say that uh to even
even in parenting situations like
when parents introduce their kids to
people they're inspired by
that will help the kids more than
telling the kids to do the right thing
and i've seen that happen so often
when you look at sports as well like
even if your father was the best actor
or best sports player in the world or
your mother was the best
tennis player or performer or whatever
it is you're never impressed by your
parents
like we're really impressed by our
family when we're younger we we get
gratitude later on
but in our early days we don't have that
but we need to meet people so if you can
introduce your family to people they're
inspired by that's going to make a huge
difference
and the final one like i said at the
start was just your example
seeing you really change seeing your
behavior change your language change
your communication change
that's going to give them the greatest
confidence that you know what she's
doing is right
it works right the proof's in the
pudding the proofs in seeing you
actually
make that change now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your specific plan of action
for the next
week when you just watch a video and get
motivated by it you have a 35
chance of following through but when you
get motivated and then create
a specific plan of action you have a 91
chance of following through that's what
we do here believe nation we get
motivated but then we do
something about it and when you commit
to other people you increase your
chances
even further of following through so
what was your biggest takeaway from this
video
and then what is your plan of action
around for this week
put it down in the comments below
because i want to celebrate
you i really believe that you have to
seek
the love and the beauty that you want in
what you have now
because that way you're training
yourself to extract
meaning right now which means in the
short term
if you can like those hospital workers
we're doing
if you can fill that role with meaning
and
your true passion and what's coming from
you
then that's going to lead you to
discovering the power of it and i saw
that in my own life when i
came back from being a monk and i worked
in the corporate world
i was teaching meditation and
mindfulness and the things that i talked
today
in the corporate world and i remember in
2014
i was invited by one of our executives
to teach mindfulness to a thousand of my
peers
at twickenham rugby stadium and i was
speaking in between the ceo
and will greenwood who won the rugby
world cup with england
and and i'm sitting there in the
audience as a complete nobody
and completely around people who are my
same age we all make the same money
no one knows who i am and there i'm
sitting there going
how am i going to share mindfulness but
after doing that experience
i realized that even though my job was
digital strategy
and social media innovation and i was a
consultant
i was bringing my passion to the
workplace
which actually gave me confidence that i
could do this outside of the workplace
and that's how the two ideas connect
that when you find how you can apply it
to your small world
you then get the confidence and the
courage to take it out and make
something real of it
whereas i think a lot of us are waiting
for that break
to get into doing it in reality but we
actually haven't even tested it or
experimented on it
in a small space where we can develop
our
our own confidence and courage around it
hey if you want more top 10 rules videos
they are no longer on this channel i
have a dedicated brand new channel just
for them
if you want to check it out go subscribe
the link is right there next to me
lots of great content go there go check
it out and continue to believe
and i'll see you there